this is a production of Cornell
University
oh man okay thanks Jenny
apparently although you already know my
life
um my name is Maria and today I'm going
to be sharing some of the work I've been
doing for the past couple years can you
guys all hear me okay okay awesome uh
hopefully by the end of this
presentation I'll be able to convince
you that nitrogen and mobilization
should be included as a weed management
tool in an integrative weed management
toolbox so
um
as you all mentioned I used to work in
strawberries and life was really good
because I always had an abundance of
fresh and frozen strawberries and now I
work in Weeds and they're amazing but um
not quite as delicious
so you might wonder why I am doing weed
management
uh weeds are a really critical component
of crop management so there there's a
study that looked at crops around the
world and uh saw that weeds caused more
crop loss than any other Pest Management
problem
um and then there's another study
looking at just corn and soybeans in the
United States and Canada and they
estimated that without weed control we
could lose up to over 50 percent of our
crops so wheat control is really
important for all crop managers except
maybe in controlled environment
agriculture
um
but they're currently facing a lot of
issues
so conventional Growers rely
predominantly on herbicides but when you
apply herbicides to a field you're
exerting a really strong selection
pressure on that weed community and
therefore weeds often evolve resistance
through natural genetic mutation to uh
the different herbicides that people use
so here we have a graph showing the
increase in herbicide resistant weeds
that we see around the world and then
once a grower has an herbicide resistant
weed Community they often use an
additional herbicide on that field and
that exerts a second selection pressure
on that weed community so weeds then
evolve resistance to multiple herbicide
modes of action and when I say mode of
action I just mean a way that the
herbicide kills a weed so there are a
lot of weed communities that are
resistant to multiple herbicide modes of
action and then this leads to increases
in costs for The Growers so when a
grower has herbicide resistant Weeds on
their Farm costs can increase between 50
to 100 percent
um so that comes from increased
herbicide applications as well as
increased seed costs
but uh conventional Growers aren't the
only ones that face feed management
challenges organic Growers could also
benefit from additional non-herbicide
based weed management tools
um
currently the options available to them
are much more complex and they also are
less reliable and only provide moderate
control and there are often trade-offs
between the tools so one of the
predominant methods of weed control for
organic Growers is tillage and that can
lead to reductions in soil Health
erosions through wind and water so they
have to make these trade-offs
so basically both organic and
conventional Growers could really
benefit from more non-erbicide based
weed management tools and so that
motivated Tony Jenny and I to look
through the literature and and try to
find a tool that could be used in
agricultural systems
and something that had been used to
restore native species growth in
prairies over invasive species growth
was nitrogen and mobilization through
carbon amendments and just so happened
that Jed had most recently published in
this area actually looking at
landscapes in Hawaii but we thought we
might be able to use nitrogen
immobilization as a tool in agricultural
systems but before I continue on talking
about nitrogen and mobilization I want
to make sure everyone's on the same page
about what it what it actually is
thank you
so nitrogen immobilization is
predominantly affected or controlled by
the soil microbial community and
microbes have a c to n ratio of about
seven to one so this is a an average
obviously there are microbes that have
higher lower CDN ratios and then
microbial communities that have higher
lower aceta n ratios
but they generally need a food source of
about 23 to one because they lose some
carbon to respiration as well as other
metabolic inefficiencies
but AG soils often have a c to n ratio
between 14 to 1 to 20 to 1. so you can
see that's a little lower than their
metabolic needs so if you add carbon
amendments to the soil then you can
alleviate that carbon constraint so
plant residues really vary in their C to
n ratios so you can have lower seat end
ratios about 20 to 1 and you can have
C10 ratios much higher than 100 to 1. so
if we choose a plant material that has a
higher C to n ratio we may able may be
able to cause nitrogen immobilization
so basically if we think about another
way we're adding carbon to the soil
it stimulates the growth of the soil
microbial Community as those microbes
grow they take up nitrogen from the soil
and that leaves less available nitrate
in the soil for the plant roots
and you may think that this is going to
reduce plant growth for all plant
species and and that may be true but
when plants fix uh carbon from
photosynthesis from the Sun
um they then have to spend that energy
either growing or having differential
growth so that may be defense mechanisms
such as Thorns or metabolites that may
help them
um
uh have reduced disease resistance or
increased disease resistance
um so because plants allocate their
resources differently they're going to
have different life histories or growth
habits
so we can see that we would imagine that
some plants would grow better in high
nitrogen soils and some plants would
grow better in lower nitrogen soils and
from the literature and from research
people have have noticed General trends
that in high nitrogen soils we often
have plants that are better at competing
for light they have higher dispersal
ability they have higher Leaf to shoot
ratios and they hire photosynthetic
capacity and maybe able to grow faster
but in low nitrogen soils we have plants
that are better at using abiotic
resources they have better or more below
ground Investments so higher root to
shoe ratios and they may be a little bit
slower growing
so if we put those two ideas together of
nitrogen immobilization in different
growth strategies in plants
if we have an AG soil where we don't
amend the soil and two plants one is
going to be better at taking up nitrogen
and then it may out-compete the other
plant
if we have another soil where we've
amended with carbon we're going to
stimulate nitrogen and mobilization
there's going to be less available
nitrogen and potentially the other plant
is going to be able to be more
successful and many of our agricultural
weeds go really well in high nitrogen
soil so we see a lot of this and
potentially there are crops or areas
where we can use this strategy to have
more of a scenario that we see on the
bottom
yeah
so we thought nitrogen immobilization
could be used in agricultural fields in
some situations and what I'm going to do
from here on out is talk about three of
my experiments that I did for my PhD and
I'm going to talk about them with
specific hypotheses that kind of ran
through all of my research
so the first hypothesis was that carbon
amendments can enhance nitrogen
immobilization so for that I'm going to
be talking about data from chapter two
my second hypothesis is that carbon
amendments can reduce the competitive
advantage of nitrogen responsive weeds
so for that I'm going to be talking
about data that I have in chapters three
and four
and my third hypothesis is that carbon
amendments can change microbial
Community composition and also their
function
so I'll actually be showing some data
from all three of my experiments
so that first question is whether high
carbon amendments can actually
immobilize nitrogen
oh
I just noticed that I have a lot of
chats is there any questions okay cool
uh so my chapter two data I use to help
answer the question of whether nitrogen
mobilization can be caused by carbon
amendments and so for this experiment we
had five gallon pots that were buried in
a field and we removed all the soil and
homogenized it and then we added a
little bit back we put in this resin bag
that you see here which absorbs anions
from the soil so we could see the
availability of nitrate throughout the
duration of the experiment
and then we amended half of our soil
with sawdust and sugar as high carbon
amendments and then we left the other
half unamended and then filled the pots
with those different treatment soils
we planted eight different weed species
in the pots but just one species per pot
and replicated each plant species and
soil amendment treatment five times
and so we predicted that microbial
biomass would be higher and that soil
nitrate would be lower in carbon amended
soils if we were to have nitrogen
immobilization happening so we looked at
this uh the microbial Community biomass
with a chloroform fumigation extraction
method and basically for that we just
had soils and we killed all of our
microbes with chloroform and then
extracted the carbon and nitrogen from
those soils to measure microbial biomass
and then we measured nitrogen
availability by extracting the nitrate
that had accumulated in that resin bag
throughout the experiment and then using
a high throughput chlorometric method to
measure nitrate availability
and first I'm going to show you
microbial biomass we've looked at both
microbial biomass carbon as well as
microbial biomass nitrogen and for the
rest of my experiment you're going to
see that uh bars are points that are
orange are amended with carbon and then
bars are points that are teal are
unamended
so for both microbial biomass carbon and
nitrogen we see a significant decrease
in our unamended soils significantly
higher in our carbon emitted soil so
this indicates when we're adding carbon
to the soil we are stimulating microbial
growth
then we looked at nitrogen availability
with that nitrate from the resin bag
and we see that we had significantly
more nitrate available in our unamended
soils and less nitrate available in our
carbon emendant soil so this indicates
to us that we are actually causing
nitrogen and mobilization with carbon
amendments
um so yeah the first hypothesis carbon
amendments can stimulate nitrogen
immobilization
and so our second hypothesis was that
carbon events can then reduce the
competitive ability of nitrogen
available weeds so I'm going to talk
about data from two different
experiments for this
first we looked at crop weed competition
in a greenhouse experiment and so for
this experiment I had five different
plants three of them were weeds and
these are common nitrogen responsive
weeds in North America and they're
really problematic in many different
growing systems we have Palmer amaranth
Powell amaranth and then common Lamb's
quarters
and then we actually had two soybean
varieties and then these two soybeans
had the same parents but one variety was
able to nodulate and then the other
variety was not able to nodulate very
well so we thought that the
non-nodulating soybean would respond
more similarly to the weeds and that the
soybean that was able to nodulate would
be able to rely on nitrogen fixed from
the atmosphere and wouldn't be as
negatively affected by the carbon
amendments and reduced nitrogen
availability in the soil
so we planted each of these five plants
in pots in competition with themselves
so we had one pot with two plants we
always had one pot with two plants so we
had monocultures of each of the
different plants and then we also
planted all of the different weed
species in competition with the two
different soybean varieties
and then we also had the two soybean
varieties in competition with one
another as well
half of the pots we left unamended and
then halfway amended with carbon and we
replicated each of those pot
combinations uh six times
and we predicted that weed above ground
growth would be lower but that soybean
growth would remain unchanged in carbon
amended soils and so we used a general
linear mix model to analyze this with um
plant above ground and root biomass as
our predictor variable or response
variables
and then we had our soil amendment
treatment the plant species or Variety
in the case of soybeans that we're
looking at
um plant competition and then the uh
interactions between soil amendment and
that plant species and soil amendment
and the plant it was in competition with
as the predictor variables
and we also included pot as a random
effect
so I'm going to show above ground above
ground biomass first and you can see on
the x-axis that we have our five
different plants our three weed species
and then our two soybean varieties
and even though you can't actually see
carbon amended bars for our three weed
species it's because we had really low
growth almost zero growth in those three
weed species and that's significantly
lower than the growth of our sweet
species and unamended soils and uh we
did not have a statistically
significantly lower biomass in our
carbon emended soils for our soybeans so
they did not respond but the uh or at
least not as dramatically as our weed
species
and then for our root biomass we see the
exact same Trend where we have
significant reductions in root biomass
for our three weed species but we don't
see a significant reduction in our
soybean varieties
so that's uh cool that they are
responding differently to the same soil
amendment treatment
but we also wanted to look at
competitive ability it can actually be a
little bit difficult to measure
competitive ability of different plant
species so we came up with a competitive
Advantage index and so what this means
is that we took the average plant
biomass when it was grown in monoculture
and then we subtracted the plant biomass
of that same species when it was grown
in polyculture so when it was grown in
competition with a different species
or variety
and then if the plant remained if the
plant biomass remained the same in
monoculture and polyculture then there
was no response
but if it was larger in polyculture then
there it had competitive advantage
and if it was smaller then it had a
competitive disadvantage
so keeping that equation in mind
for our soybeans whether we amended the
soils with carbon or left them unamended
we had no change in competitive
advantage and it was the same for our
non-nodulating soybeans
but are weed species you can see a
significant reduction in competitive
Advantage when you amend the carbon so
we thought that was really cool and um
kind of emphasize that carbon amendments
can change crop weed competition
we wanted to see if these results had uh
hold in a field experiment oftentimes
things that you see in a greenhouse
don't translate super well into the
field
so we had a field experiment in
Freeville where we had five different
soil amendment treatments and they
increased in carbon as you move to the
right or yeah to your right
um two remained unamended we had a
weed-free control and then a weedy
control
then we had a rye hay treatment a
sawdust treatment and then treatment
where we added the sawdust and Rye hay
together and so you can see these are
increasing in total amount of carbon
but the C to n ratio is actually highest
in our sawdust Amendment treatment so
this let us kind of tease apart whether
total carbon added to the soil or the C
to n ratio was more important for
nitrogen and mobilization and weed
control
if we planted both corn and soybeans in
this field and the corn we've banned
fertilized to help alleviate some of the
stress of nitrogen and mobilization for
the corn and soybeans we thought could
fix their own nitrogen and again would
not be as significantly affected by
nitrogen immobilization we repeated this
experiment for two years but the data
I'm going to show you is only from the
second year of the experiment
we've we predicted that we'd biomass and
the community composition of the weeds
would be would vary based on the C to n
ratio of the soil amendment so again I
used a general linear mixed model and
the data I'm going to show you are weed
above ground biomass and the community
composition of the weeds in the in the
plots and what we did to to get this
data is we did biomass Clips in
mid-august to uh because we predicted
that that would have the highest total
weed biomass throughout the season
we identified all the weed species
within a quarter meter square and dried
them and then weigh them so we knew who
was there and also how much was there
our predictor variables were just our
soil amendment treatments and then we
also included block as a random effect
and uh we analyzed corn and separate and
soybeans separately because they're on
two different sides of the field
these are kind of like separate
experiments and then you can see I only
have four treatments along the bottom
because these are all the soil amendment
treatments relative to the weed free
control
um and on the y-axis we just have the
total weed biomass again relative to the
weed free control which essentially had
zero weed biomass
but for corn you can see we had our
highest weed biomass in our right hand
minute plot and our lowest weed biomass
in our sawdust amended plot so this
sawdust Amendment remember it didn't
have the the most total carbon added to
the soil but it had the highest C to n
ratio so that kind of indicates to us
that the C to end ratio is more
important for nitrogen and mobilization
and reducing plant growth or weed growth
and for soybeans we see the exact same
Trend raihi having the highest total
weed biomass in sawdust having the
lowest weed biomass
so we're seeing a reduction in total
weed growth but we were also curious if
this was changing the community
composition and so we looked at this a
couple different ways
um the first way I'm going to show you
is we looked up several wheat species
traits in the literature
we used we looked up seed Mass uh the
Ellenberg nitrogen index which is an
indicator of how responsive that weed
species is or that plant species is to
nitrogen in the soil and then the leaf
area index
so we looked those traits up and then we
multiplied them by our weed count data
of our in our actual experiment
and then we found the mean value of
those three traits per plot and because
we wanted it to be weighted we then
divided it by the total number of weeds
that we had in that plot
so again so keeping that equation in
mind
uh two of the plant traits were
significantly affected by our soil
amendment treatments the Ellenberg
nitrogen index and the specific Leaf
area and if we look at Ellenberg
nitrogen index we see our highest index
in our Rye hate plots which makes sense
because we're adding a significant
amount of nitrogen to that plot and our
Sonos amended plots had the lowest
Ellenberg nitrogen and X species on
average and then for specific Leaf area
during post-talk analyzes it didn't
actually have significant differences
between the treatments but you see the
same Trend with Rye hay having the
highest specific Leaf area and sawdust
having the lowest specific heat area
we also looked at our weed species
Community using an indicator species
analysis and what an indicator species
analysis does is it looks at two traits
it looks at the positive predictive
value of a species and the Fidelity of a
species so the positive predictive value
is asking in the question does this
species occur in sites belonging to this
group only so you can see in my little
example that we have red species that
are only found in teal plots so that
species is going to have a high
predictive value
and Fidelity asked the questions ask the
question how many sites in this group
have this species so here we have red
species that are found in every single
teal plot so this red species is going
to have high fidelity so species that
have high positive predictive value and
High Fidelity can be indicator species
of a specific treatment
so we ran this on all the different weed
species that we saw in our uh
experiments
and we found several weed species that
had a significant uh predictive value
and what I thought was kind of
interesting about this data what I want
to point out to you
is that they were all the species were
pretty much predictive of uh soil
amendment treatments that included Rye
hay so that again is adding a fair
amount of nitrogen to our soil
so I think considering both the weed
species Community traits that we looked
at and the indicator species analysis
that actually in the two years of our
experiment we're really selecting only
for species that have uh high that grow
well in high nitrogen soils because we
only repeated this for two years and so
we may have only had time within those
two years to select for relatively fast
growing species
um but if we continue this experiment
for more than two years possibly we
would have started to see selection for
species that had uh that would have been
done better in low nitrogen soils so we
didn't see any species indicator species
in our sawdust Amendment amended plots
for example but um we may started have
started to see those
if we continue the experiment
so again going back to my hypotheses
we've looked at nitrogen immobilization
we've looked at changes in crop weed
competition especially of nitrogen
responsive weeds
um
I now want to talk about carbon
amendments and how they can change
microbial community structure and
function but before I start talking
about microbes I want to check and see
if there are any questions about plants
because we're going to a little bit
leave plants
no okay
so
we know that microbial communities are
really important for ecological
functioning they affect both soil
processes as well as plant growth
um and we would know we would expect
that microbial communities would change
similarly to plant communities based on
resource availability
we know a little bit less about or a lot
less I'd say about microbes in general
um but in high nitrogen soils we would
expect to see higher bacterial to fungal
ratios because bacteria have generally a
lower C to n ratio requirement
um and we would expect to see maybe
copiotrophic are selected to our faster
growing uh microbes
and then in high carbon amended soils we
would expect maybe to see lower
bacterial fungal ratios because fungi
have a higher C to n ratio requirement
and potentially with the ability to
decompose complex organic matter
um and so we wanted to look at the
microbial communities in our own soils
and we did this using culture
independent methods so we didn't grow
these microbes in the lab we just were
able to look at the microbes that had
grown in our soils during our experiment
so I'm going to go through
um some data from all three of my
experiments
and for all of them to look at the
microbial Community we extracted the DNA
directly from the soil and then we
Amplified different regions of that DNA
to look at bacterial versus fungal
communities so for bacteria we're going
to look at the 16s region and then for
fungi we're going to look at the its
region
and then we use those sequence regions
to come up with a taxonomic
classification and so in microbial
ecology we don't call these uh species
bacterial and fungal species because we
often don't know them down to species
level we call them operational taxonomic
units because we may only know them down
to class or order our phylum level but
I'm going to kind of use both words so
that those of you who don't usually
think about operational taxonomic units
that you'll understand that it's kind of
analogous to species
um and then when we get this data back
it's highly dimensional so we have one
soil and it will have thousands of
bacteria or fungi in that soil and it's
hard to find Trends
um using looking at this data so what we
do is we create a distance Matrix with
that highly dimensional data and so
um distances that are closer together so
smaller distances have microbial
communities that are more similar to one
another
and distances that are further apart so
a higher number is are going to have
microbial communities are that are more
different from one another
um for those of you who use distance
matrixes we used to break Curtis
distance Matrix because it does well
um with zeros
but there are many different ways to
calculate how similar or different a
microbial Community would be to one
another
and then we plot that distance Matrix in
multi-dimensional space and it can be
difficult to see Trends
um in an environment like that so we use
a principal coordinates analysis to
simplify this data so basically what a
principal coordinates analysis does is
it finds two planes within that data set
that explain the greatest amount of
variability of all of those points
so those the X and Y axis that you're
that you're going to see in the next few
graphs they don't inherently mean
anything they're just two axes that
explain as much variability as we can
um and the x-axis always explains the
most amount of variability so when you
see my graphs I'll actually it will
indicate how much variability it's
explaining and then the y-axis always
explains the second most amount of
variability
and then what we do is we just color or
shape the points to visually see Trends
based on our soil or different
treatments so and again we're just
looking for visual clusters uh points
that are more similar are closer
together in terms of their microbial
community and points that are further
apart are more different
Okay so
um for we're first going to go through
bacterial uh communities and uh from
chapter two remember this is the the
experiment where I buried pots in a
field uh and I had eight different weed
species growing so my different weed
species are going to be different shapes
and then the soil amendment treatments
are going to be carbon amended are going
to be orange unamended teal
and you can see pretty clear separation
of my soil amendment or my bacterial
communities based on soil amendment
treatments and our statistics back up
that trend
um oh oh yeah good okay for chapter
three is our Greenhouse experiment um
and we see the uh the same thing where
we have pretty clear separation uh based
on soil amendment treatments and again
uh supported by our statistics
and for chapter four that's our field
experiment and again these are just
bacterial communities you can actually
see the oh
oh this is showing fungi I think I
skipped a few
okay
well spoiler alert spoiler alert both
bacteria and fungi responded really
strongly to soil amendment treatments um
you can see it in all three of my
experiments
um
yeah so you've already seen this graph I
guess just very quickly uh the one thing
I want to mention about chapter four so
this is my field experiment we're
actually seeing stronger selection based
on year but within the year we're also
seeing selection based on these soil
amendment treatments which are these
different colors here okay so we're
seeing the same selection for uh both
bacteria and fungi
but it's not telling us which microbes
are causing that change it's just saying
that they're different based on soil
amendment treatment so there are many
different ways that we can go about uh
figuring out which species are most
important for causing those changes and
the one I I used for this chapter 2 Data
um again this field pod experiment is
um the random Forest method this is a
fairly commonly used machine learning
algorithm where we have a data set where
we have all of our different uh species
in this case I'm just going to show you
fungi because there was a really strong
effect of our fungal species so it's
nice to show as an example
um so it takes all of our fungal species
that we found in the soil it takes a
random subset of those fungi it makes a
decision tree of whether the soils were
amended with carbon or were unamended
and then it does that again it does that
like 500 times and then I take the speed
then it rates the species that were most
accurately able to
split the soils in carbon amended or
unamended and it gives those a highest
score so I took my 20 highest most
predictive fungal species and I just
looked at those so I didn't have to look
at the other you know thousands of fungi
I wanted to see if these fungi were more
abundant in carbon abundant soils or
whether they were more abundant in
unamended soils so I made a visual Tool
uh called a heat map and what a heat map
is it's just a grid
and then each row is going to be a
fungal otu or fungal species and
remember I'm just looking at the top 20
most predictive fungal species and then
each column is a pot so I had 80
different pots in this experiment so
um I'll have 80 columns and then the
color each box is going to be colored in
and each color shows microbial abundance
um if the microbe was not abundant it's
going to be yellow but if it was highly
abundant in that in that pot it's going
to be purple
and then just for ease of analysis I'm
going to have unamended pots on one side
and carbon have ended on other
and so hopefully what you can see now is
that all of the 20 most predictive
species were highly or were more
abundant in my carbon emended soils and
often absent actually in my undermended
soils
so I can I can take a look at what these
species are but I think this uh table
kind of highlights why it's a little bit
difficult to analyze microbial data we
know these are really important microbes
or fungi for my um experiment but we
don't know much about them some we don't
even know to phylum level
but a lot of them you can see are by
city of mycota and this one asked my
code as well we know it decomposes
carbon compounds so we could uh or um
wood compounds so we could think that uh
with sawdust amendments we're selecting
for fun gold species that are able to
decompose wood which kind of makes sense
but it's cool to see that like the data
is backing that up
okay I've got a couple more minutes I
think I can run through the last thing I
wanted to show you
um so we also wanted to look at
microbial Community function and this
can be uh there are different ways that
people can do this but one way people
use is through shotgun metagenomics
where they amplify all the DNA in the
soil and then look and see what genetic
functions does that soil contain
um that is quite costly and we do not
have the funds or the time to do that
because all my experiments had a lot of
replicates and a lot of different
treatments so we uh can instead actually
infer that same data using the amplicon
sequences that I that I already had
um
and we can only currently do this for
bacterial species and the the tool that
that is that this is called is pie crust
2 and it's just a computational tool
um
so I used this tool for the bacterial
communities in my Greenhouse experiment
but I really want to emphasize that this
tool only comes up with potential
estimated functions of our microbial
Community it's not something that we
measure directly basically it takes the
bacterial otu data it allows them to
reference sequences it places those in a
reference tree it infers Gene copy
number
predicts again this is a prediction of
Gene family abundance
and then infer sample pathway abundance
but
this reference trees are often based on
microbes that we're able to grow in the
lab so culture dependent methods and so
we're really reducing the amount of
genetic information that is contained in
our soils
and each step is an estimate so we're
really compounding the degrees of
variability in each of these steps so I
just really want to emphasize I'm going
to show you some results but they're
estimates
but what we did see is that our
potential metabolic pathways that were
more abundant in unamended soils
compared to carbon amended soils in this
greenhouse experiment we're generally
synthesis Pathways so right now
um I only am showing you the pathways
that were more abundant unamended soils
so the microbes are doing a secondary
metabolite biosynthesis nucleotide
biosynthesis
carbohydrate biosynthesis and this is
kind of in
um contrast to the metabolic pathway
estimates that were more abundant in
carbon emended soil so these metabolic
pathways are generally more degradation
pathways their secondary metabolite
degradation amine degradation alcohol
degradation and um actually this
unclassified super pathway at the top
that's just all the pathways that we
don't know anything about so I think
that highlights some of the variability
that uh and and why it's difficult to to
analyze microbiome data
but I think that kind of shows that
um
microbial communities can really be
selected for based on nutrient
availability and then they can have
potentially different functions and that
has ramifications for things such as
carbon use efficiency where in high
carbon soils we may be just degrading
those carbon compounds and have uh that
may explain why we see lower carbon use
efficiency in carbon amended soils
um and then that may have ramifications
for soil carbon storage but of course my
research did not address these questions
but I I hope that it um Can highlight
the importance of the microbial
Community for ecological functioning
um so
we've addressed all three of these
hypotheses
um but I want to zoom back out
and say that nitrogen immobilization is
really important for weed control
um people use uh cover cropping as a
weed control tool and mulching as a weed
control tool and both of these are
probably immobilizing nitrogen there's
been several studies especially with
cover cropping that looked at nitrogen
mobilization so I hope that this
research can go improve cover crop
design and mold selection and use
and I also also hope that we can
increase the use of nitrogen
immobilization in the future as uh our
Ag Systems become more data driven so we
might be able to go into a field and
identify areas where we have nitrogen
responsive weeds and high soil nitrogen
availability and then think about uh use
our increasingly accurate soil carbon
decomposition models to figure out where
we should put that carbon and which
source of carbon is going to be best for
mobilizing nitrogen during the critical
period of weed control
and then take an applicator and actually
apply that that carbon in specific areas
in the field
uh so yeah I want to make sure I leave
time for questions but also I really
want to thank um everyone who made this
research possible of course my committee
uh and everyone who's come into the come
in and out of the labs that I've been
part of
um as well as people who've helped
sponsor my work
um been mentors to me and um helped with
Statistics and field work and I also
want to just do a brief shout out to all
the people who've made my life outside
of Cornell um really meaningful and made
my time here uh just really wonderful so
uh I think I have a couple minutes for
questions I'll leave on this slide
okay Marvin so so if you use a cover
crop for nitrogen immobilization and
then you spot get a big flush of
nitrogen release or are you sort of
forced into a situation where to keep
adding for a long time yeah that's a
great question yeah so Marvin is asking
about we're going to say we're using
nitrogen immobilization in a cover crop
and then we we are no longer using a
cover crop are we just going to have a
flush of nitrogen and I think the short
answer is probably uh yes but that it's
going to come at a more at a slower rate
and um depending upon the cover crop
that we're adding especially if we
choose one with a higher C to n ratio
we're going to not be adding a lot of
nitrogen so it'll just be the nitrogen
that's already in the soil and then that
will then become available so I think
that kind of plays into uh figuring out
how long we want nitrogen mobilization
to be happening and and
um what crops we're planting like we'd
probably want that nitrogen for some
crops and some others we don't need it
so so yeah so that would definitely play
a role time definitely is a huge role in
the back
um sorry if I didn't catch this but
we're looking at the immobilization in
the first study yeah when you were
measuring the nitrate in the resin
um were you also looking at ammonium
yeah
no yeah no that's a great question so
she was asking about nitrate and
ammonium and so for that particular
experiment we only
um used looked at nitrate um because we
were just using uh resin beads that
would absorb um anions uh however you
can get beads that or resins that absorb
anions and cations and actually in our
field experiment we did look at nitrate
and ammonium and we saw reductions in
over the season in in nitrate but
actually interestingly we saw a slight
increase in ammonium levels in carbon
amended soils
um yeah so that's a great question I was
wondering if it could be shifting forms
yeah I think yeah
mobilization also yeah yeah exactly so
so yeah it's not like we just have well
yeah this is great so we we don't just
have nitrogen just standing there it's
all is in flux and so exactly like you
said
um we think that we're actually seeing
an accumulation of ammonium in some of
those soils because it's come it's yeah
it's just not transforming into nitrate
so it's yeah differentially abundant for
different plants which plays into uh the
selection for different plant species
yeah yeah thanks for that question okay
oh Aaliyah has a question
so on like around like in the mid 40s
like probably around 5 45 like you said
how like it showed how these um
the community they spatially separated
not only within treatment but they seem
to spatially separate even more by year
so like in 2020 they clustered more to
throw together than 2021 uh no yeah
right there 2021 they really tend to
separate and do you think that's
potentially due to a legacy effect of
and do you think that separation would
expand even more if you continued it
over the the number of years and I guess
the final part sorry for the long
question is do you think if you expanded
this since microbial communities might
be more quickly responsive that if this
was perhaps like a five-year study or a
10-year study you would see a similar
Trend in terms of Separation in Weak
communities and potentially separating
based off of fecundity or RK selection
oh yeah okay that's great that's a great
question so Alia is asking about
separation between years and then also
how we're seeing like a greater spread
here in 2021 uh compared to 2020.
um and there's so many parts of that and
I I feel like I'm kind of going to go
off on a bit of a tangent that's maybe
even unrelated to what you just asked
um so one thing that we noticed in uh
this experiment especially is that we're
actually seeing really strong I didn't
mention this because I didn't have I
didn't think I had enough time but um
so both of these points up here they're
the Rye hay emitted treatments and the
sawdust and raheemed treatment
all these points down here don't include
Rai hay and so uh we know that arai hay
actually has a lot of allelopathic
compounds and so we're thinking that
potentially here we're actually seeing
selection based on those allelopathic
compounds or they also are adding rihei
is adding a fair amount of nitrogen so
it could be a nitrogen response in the
microbial Community it could also be I
think because these are so tightly like
kind of overlapped I almost have the
idea that it's an allelopathic compound
uh response or something specific to Rye
hay itself
um so I talk about that in the paper a
little bit but we don't usually people
use a leelopathic compounds as a weed
control tool but actually these two
treatments ha um
had a fair amount of weed biomass so we
think that the the allelopathic compound
is selecting for microbial communities
but it's not seeming to select for
um plant communities what seems to be
the stronger selector for plant
communities is the amount of uh nitrogen
and we are seeing already a little bit
of selection for nitrogen responsive
plant species
um yeah so does that kind of answer the
different parts those nitrogen those
nitrogenes tend to be particularly pecan
they tend to be large seed producers on
top yeah we didn't look at seed numbers
that would have been a good one to look
up or count but did not have time but um
they uh we did look at seed mass and we
really thought seed Mass might because
usually for plants will have smaller
seed Mass but we didn't actually see a
response in seed Mass yet but we yeah
maybe if we continued for a longer
period of time we would have I don't
know
so I've got one from Geneva Caroline
marshmallow said uh can you tell us more
about three fungal species that were
present in both treated and untreated
plots or bacterial the heat map slide
all yellow except for the three species
oh yeah okay thanks Carrie okay yeah so
um Carrie's asking about these three
species that are in our unamended plots
um
which are the only species that are in
anonymity plots that were most uh
predictive for carbon and versus
unamended these uh actually these two
species here are still more abundant in
unamended soils than they are in
carbon-emended soils you can see they're
kind of like blue and light green in our
unemitted soils but they're actually
purple in our carbon amended soil so
that means they're more abundant so I I
still think that
um we're selecting for increased growth
in carbon amended pots for these two but
this one down here is actually more
abundant in unamended soils than it is
in carbon emitted soil so if we go to
this next slide we can see it's an
ascomycota
and we can see we know it down to
species level but uh but try to come I I
didn't see anything in the literature
that would like particularly say whether
I didn't know what conclusion to draw
from it it's you know it's we can see
this fungal species it can cause
diseases but um it didn't seem
particularly
I don't know what else to say about it
yeah so yeah I think this kind of
highlights some of the difficulties in
in
um
analyzing microbial communities is that
you don't always know what the species
are who they are what they do what the
importance is sorry Carrie
any more questions
okay well thank you very very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu